what i want to do in this video is
introduce you to the idea of sigma
notation which will be used extensively
through your mathematical career so
let's just say you wanted to find a sum
of some terms and these terms have a
pattern so let's say you want to find
the sum of the first ten numbers you
could say one plus two plus three plus
and you go all the way to plus nine
plus ten and i clearly could have even
written this whole thing out but you can
imagine it becomes a lot harder if you
wanted to find the sum of the first
hundred numbers so that would be one
plus two plus three plus and
you would go all the way to ninety-nine
plus one hundred
so mathematicians said well there must
let's find some way to
some notation instead of having to do
this dot dot dot thing which you will
see sometimes done so that we can more
cleanly express these types of sums and
that's where sigma notation comes from
so this sum up here right right over
here this first one it could be
represented at as and sigma this use a
capital sigma this greek letter right
over here and what you do is you define
an index and you could say and you could
start your index at some value so let's
say your index starts at one it also use
i for index so let's say that i starts
at one
and i'm going to go to ten so i starts
at one and it goes to ten
and i'm going to sum up the eyes so how
does this translate into this right over
here
well what you do is you start wherever
the index is the index is at one
set i equal to one write the one down
and then you increment the index and so
i will then be equal to 2
i is 2 put the 2 down and you're summing
each of these terms as you go and you go
all the way until i is equal to 10 all
the way until i is equal to 10. so given
what i just told you i encourage you to
pause this video and write the sigma
notation for this sum right over here
assuming you've given a go at it well
this would be the sum
the first term well it might be easy to
say we'll start at i equals one again
i
equals one but now we're not going to
stop until i equals a hundred and we're
going to sum up we're going to sum up
all of the i's
let's do another example let's imagine
the sum
let's imagine the sum
from
from just from i equals
i equals 0
to
of i don't know let me say pi
pi i squared pi i squared what would
this sum look like and once again i
encourage you to pause the video and
write it out i kind of expand out this
sum well let's just go step by step
i when i equals 0 this will be pi times
0 squared and that's clearly 0 but i'll
write it out pi
times
0 squared then we increase our i and we
will make sure that we haven't hit this
that we our i isn't already this top
boundary right over here or this top
value so now we said i equals one
pi times one squared so plus
plus
pi plus pi times one squared
one times one squared well is one our
top value right over here where we stop
no so we keep going so then we go i
equals two pi times 2 squared so plus
plus pi
times
2 squared
pi times 2 squared i think you see the
pattern here and we're just going to
keep going all the way until at some
point we're going to keep incrementing
our i i is going to be 49 so it's going
to be pi times 49 squared
pi times 49 squared and then finally we
increment i i equal becomes 50 and we're
going to have plus
pi times
pi
times 50 squared
and then we say okay our i is finally
equal to this top boundary and now we
can stop and so you can see this
notation this sigma notation for this
sum was a much cleaner way a much purer
way of representing this than having to
write out the entire sum but you'll see
people switch back and forth between the
two